I'm actually going to not solve this
question immediately I'm actually going
to use this as our way to demonstrate
that we need a better way to soul then
rectangular form okay let's have a look
at this guy he said to the six equals to
negative 64 okay now if I try to pull
the same trick that I am cool babypea
but I can take that 64 over the other
side and then I'm just gonna stop right
about there right because unlike with
the sum or difference of cubes or some
examples where I don't have anything
foot somehow six nor for anything else
for that matter I don't have to four or
five I don't have any other numbers okay
so therefore this way of just doing it
in rectangular form is not significant
it's not enough so what I need to do is
I need to appeal back to what we were
saying before and do it in more artful
okay so rather than attack this question
right I'm gonna type this question again
the same one but can we do it completely
in one odd form because then that'll
give us a path through is that okay can
we try this same question we know what
the answer they're going to be we know
what predicting can we do it in morning
okay you ready
we're gonna use de moivre's theorem okay
so again I've got said commute it was
one but instead of moving the one on the
other side of they try to factorize I'm
just gonna go straighten this guy right
if said is this right then I said notice
that you should be like this is that
okay so I'm gonna have this I need one
as a as a polar form as a [ __ ] formed
coughing sum up what is it the modulus
is one what's the argument of one zero
is a life on the positive real axis so
I'm gonna write that as cos 0 plus a by
sine 0 is that okay yeah on the left
hand side I haven't quite left myself
enough space but I'm going to use
democracy and write it out with the case
where N equals 3 so I'm going to have aa
cos 3 3 dot
Plus eyesight clean up okay and I'm
going to say why I know that because all
this theorem that I can court okay
so first step we're always trying to get
the modulus first because the rest of it
depends on the modulus so in this case
we've worked on this assume you know the
magis is going to be one so here you can
say R is a good one therefore taking the
one July out of the way I got this with
this be happy now - sold
I'm gonna do the same thing I want to do
my comparison of real and imaginary
parts okay now this seems like a little
more work it seems like I could have
just gone straight to the quadratic in
this case but this is going to be a much
more versatile way when we attack this
guy do you see why I'm trying to justify
this so when I equate really library
part
I'm going to get two solutions okay
we'll run our two equations right I'm
gonna get the real one this and then I'm
going to get the imaginary okay are you
happy with that okay now the reasons
that I hope will become clear in a
second I'm gonna do the right-hand side
one first we were sold for using the
imaginary part of the equation and then
I'll come back to this guy in a minute
okay if you got sight of something equal
sign us something else then clearly one
of the solutions to that is where notice
two things aren't the same do you agree
with that like sine x equals sine Y well
X&Y being the same that'll work right so
that's a solution but it's not the only
solution right think about what sign
looks like again he's the sine curve
right so there's a whole bunch of
solutions right in radians what are the
kinds of solutions that I'm getting
office can you read them for me
you've already got the first one zero
what's the next one and all PI right
I've got all the multiples of Pi I can
also go in the negative direction card I
I can have negative pi they get to
pioneer three points so on does that
make sense so this is not the only
solution right there's a whole bunch of
the other ones in fact what I can do is
that I can add now for this guy I can
add any whole number
multiple hi do you agree with that you
know any whole number I'm good
one two three four five six PI I can go
negative 1 negative 2 negative 3 PI etc
so I'm going to say plus K
kay can be any integer I want right
that'll capture the positive and the
negative Saturday so I'll say this right
now just let me make a really really
heavy summer night here right this line
we just wrote this line we just write
strictly speaking comes in another topic
that we're going to learn in treat next
year after we meet Radian measure annex
as an extension one topic this is called
general solution okay it's called
general solution because I'm not just
giving you one solution or the solution
in a particular domain I'm giving you
every single solution but it's a
generally working formula that'll give
me all the answers yes okay all right
now let me just finish off what's
happening here on the right hand side
write 0 plus K pi is just big white
right so I'll divide through and that
gives me this is that okay right now
this is not bad but I need thicker just
like I've been sort of dropping into
your head from like these cuts do I need
theta to satisfy not just one of these
equations I need both right that'll tell
me exactly where I could go so let's
have a look at this guy right now
thankfully I have the right thing on the
right hand side now okay
just like I had before one of the
solutions to cause something it was
caused something else is where those two
things are the same angle do you agree
with that so three theta equals 0 is a
solution to that equation as well that
looks promising that looks exactly the
same as this okay but hold on what does
this look like
Albus yes like that's what what does
cause what does the graph look like okay
where are my submissions where do they
come up okay now don't forget free 30
was zero right so in other words cause
of three theta equals one do you agree
with that because cos of 0 is 1 so
here's a solution right
there's 3 3 with Europe here's another
solution because they're all equal to 1
right
he's another solution I can keep on
going for Rev all right how frequently
do my solutions come on now they don't
come up quite as frequently as over here
right here I've got 0 PI 1 2 3 4 5 PI
they're all fine but that's not one pi
it's all the way at the end of the
period that's 2 pi and when I go to the
next solution again I have to go to a
whole other period I have to complete
the period so therefore I'm not PI over
there I'd you see what's going on so
cosine works a little bit differently
right it's not just multiplying adding
on multiples of Pi I have to multiply
sorry I can add by the even multiples of
Pi does that make sense
2 pi 4 PI 6 PI and I can still go in the
other direction
negative 2 pi negative 4 PI they're all
ok so I've already stated what K so I
don't need to say it again ok ok now you
have a look at this ring remember we
said I need theta to satisfy both
equations right both equations so I
needed to do this one and I need to do
that one right but only some of these
solutions are okay right but only some
of these solutions work over here in
fact exactly half of Mt I have to reject
all the odd multiples of pi do you see
that right this list effectively is dot
dot dot minus 2 pi
- pie 0xu mind and soul okay but this is
the key up is these guys zero to PI or
PI I'm missing half of them right so I
only want the ones that were both lists
the ones that satisfy both equations so
therefore this is like the more quickie
version of the arm of the solution if
you like okay so it says it's a bit like
you've got a you know in a family where
there's two siblings and one somebody
like I'll eat anything right and then
there's a picky one okay will you buy
food then what is it they can eat which
means you - this guy there's three theta
equals to K equals to K pi on three can
you see that this is again another
general solution or maybe all of the
positions of theta that I wants it only
gave me half of the ones okay now I know
the modulus there it is
I know the arguments now I'm ready to
actually state my solutions